hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreign again today
it's just gonna be a little bit of a
short video there wasn't a dev stream
and on top of that by the way the next
dev stream is going to be December 5th
which is not next week as the time I'm
making this video but the following week
after that they're gonna be discussing
the state of balance with year 3 season
3 also known as season 11 with Hulda so
that's gonna be interesting to see how
that goes so definitely be on the
lookout for that video but as always we
got some other stuff to talk about so
let's get started with today's video
obviously spectator mode had just
released a couple days ago so if you
haven't got a chance to try spectator
mode definitely go try it out and you
can leave your feedback on reddit there
definitely gonna be searching around
especially on a specific thread so that
you can know exactly what was going on
with spectator mode and all the feedback
so they can maybe change if there's some
sort of bug happening on top of that
there's also a warrior challenge which
is be the faction with the most amount
of matches completed of any type of game
mode and then you will be getting a
bunch of rewards for that so definitely
go help your faction out what that won
first place could be getting five grades
second places for and third places three
crates on top of that there's also going
to be a double xp event this weekend
going from around the afternoon time of
November 22nd to around the afternoon of
November 25th you could of course earn
double the XP at the end of every match
and on all completed orders and
contracts so definitely go do that if
you have a new character that you want
to level up or if you have an old
character that you're trying to get to
like rep 60 definitely go do that that
there's the usual arcade weekly quest
and there's also a new effect in the
shop called the route and branches this
is for all heroes it's pretty cool not
the craziest looking thing in the world
but it's always new content can't go
wrong with that so if you didn't want to
grab the root and branch it is currently
up and now yeah and that's just about it
guys let me know what you guys think
about the video in the comments below on
top of that I'll probably be streaming
this weekend during the double X big
into getting some extra reps nyan soon
da and all that stuff even though I'm
already rep 10 might as well get more
say def we go check out my twitch down
on the description I'll probably be
doing a couple streams this weekend but
other than that guys have a great
weekend peace out and good bye
you